armando hay un club de lotería en marcha
deber de exigir a los números 09 y luego en
entrada de las 26 letras del alfabeto inglés
puede ir el mismo número 2 veces si el boleto
atar los numeros de letras y mejor
mal es engañar el premio mayor y
recibe desde r 1.400 5 dolares y solo
ata la letra y el nombre de tus números
en ghana el premio mas pequeño de 100 dolares en
cualquier otro caso
fr y no recibir nada es costumbre boleto es
z 5 dólares para participar en todos y
en cualquier otro caso interno y nueve si
ve nada es elegido en la hermosa tarde
cuatro era así que supongo que paga los 5
dolares para jugar y que corran
los boletos serán cuatro r
digamos que seguimos una variable es
al azar y jueves
y esta variable es esta
en la codicia es hora de cambiar
¿Qué es la codicia y la nieta esperaba jugar?
como número 1 040 en particular y luego
tenemos que juzgar este boleto
Quiero analizar en este video este valor
esperaba este boleto con el valor
previsto
¿Cuál es el valor esperado del colector de curado?
ser los cuatro es ilusión alcance a hacer una pausa
vivía tratando de resolverlo por 50
así que pensamos que ningún valor esperado
esta es la probabilidad de cualquier hasta
sus posibles resultados
* la codicia la mitad de cada resultado que tenemos
la primera probabilidad mayor que y
dibujar celo en color ro
entonces si tenemos en la prueba de limitar
determinar en premio y x lu que ganamos
cuánto sería eso
sn gana mil 405 dolares
el objetivo es ganar el que pago la cuca
entonces 65 dolares por que si esto es
esto en sí mismo pero en la menor probabilidad
probabilidad de prima porque pagó bien
premio menor sera el dolar ahi en la porteria
Me pregunto si el premio menor
tenis y menos nosotros finalmente
tenis sobre la probabilidad de no ganar
1000 y esencialmente perder en eso
situación con ellos
cual es el meta codicia que esta en
situación de gobernanza objetivo y menos 5
dólares para pagar 75 dólares inesperadamente
regresión en teoría para encontrar valor
esperado tenemos que encontrar estos
impares
Entonces, ¿cuál es la probabilidad del premio?
lo más probable es que ni siquiera tembló en el jo
la probabilidad de que tengas el primero
letra correcta está en la pregunta para dejar en el
probabilidad que tiene en la segunda letra
correcto ya que son independientes y
probabilidad que tiene en la letra
correcto y 26 letras con el mismo
probabilidad tan pronto como el nodo 26
posibilidades entonces sesi en el
probabilidades el mayor premio es el nudo
dos mil seiscientos noventa y dos
mil seiscientos en que la probabilidad
para conseguir dinero y pm el más pequeño de o
guardabarros en 3096 menor y estar allí carta
correcto
los pavos entienden algunos números correctos
entonces si n 26 posibilidades de tener en el
letra correcta peru terminó con
solo estoy con el 96 porque este 96
incluir todos los escenarios nos define
en la letra correcta incluso en el escenario
este año el premio mayor definió el
letra y los dos números correctos
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
registre el escenario en esto - los números
correcto de los números correctos y la letra
uno en 2600 salto en 26 - en 2006
en la relación allá que tenemos sin embargo
1626 probabilidad de tener esta letra
correcto
turquía es inclusiva en el escenario cluj nf-e
todo lo correcto es mas pequeño cuando la letra e en el
ninguno de los dos numeros correctos
cuanto mayor es el premio mayor es la probabilidad
que aquí en Austria para calcular el
probabilidad de un premio menor que
animales que serán menos probables
y aquí estará lo nuevo: la probabilidad de
que hay menos premio de probabilidad en ello
de un niño - en la probabilidad de premio
más grande
los posibles resultados de vender a
unidad - la probabilidad mucho menor - en el
probabilidad mucho mayor - la
probabilidad de morir de emil martins
jô mayor premio y denuncia streck
la probabilidad es menor aquí en bien y
6 - o no
dos mil seiscientos años en 2600 y
esto aquí es el nodo
- a menor que el nodo en b en 6 - el nodo en
2006 - uno en 2600 - un nodo en 1600 y
Siempre me quedo años esto es menos
un año en Belén y en - 0 -
y por que esto se ha resentido bueno en
forma en que pierde en la forma en que
nunca nada este nieto la letra incorrecta
yen un año el 26 de enero carta
correcto y luego ver esto estará dentro
de cualquiera de estas dos categorías roth
en este año - en el en 26 que es igual a 25 es
de 16 25 26 posibilidad de tener la letra
incorrecto y nunca supe donde canadá nudo
en este caso fiergs completamente entonces
no es reglamentario y calculamos texto
- estábamos más cerca estará en el em
2,600 dividido en dos mil seiscientos
mil 405 menos 5 va a ser 2400 por 406
menos al nivel de 2005 la prima más baja
que
- 5 ai-5 y finalmente 5 en 2025 y
dividido en 26 en congo y paréntesis aquí
entiendo que para ser coherente y 25
dieciséis
esto se paga que cuando no ganamos nada
tenemos que pagar 5 dolares y no teniamos
nada por menos 5
no se si el grito estaba funcionando
pavo para 5 son y nos merecemos un problema
de tambores
tenemos una resonancia en esta espera
algarve de dolares y ii de dolares y
los servicios públicos en los estados se reúnen
caminamos y tratamos de marchar khan
así que si todo esto será igual a todos
miradas y treinta y un centavos
entonces ella tendría poco solo emergencia en el
la codicia esperará positivo como sanador
solo por la persona a cargo de la lotería es
sido el casino que es lo que tiene
arrogancia y thais para el positivo y
el jugador dijo que esperara allí
el tiro perdido se encuentra sentiría el lugar
y cuando y si quedarse solo por la mayoria
de incendios y lotería
2 a 6 de esperanza media codicia
de los dolares con ochenta y un centavos